[Music]
I do speak to some men who say I feel
like a walk in egg shells these days and
the sad thing about that if they're if
they are feeling that is that we lose I
think we lose our intelligence if we're
always feeling I have to be over
cautious or overprotective or any of
that you know there is such an important
role you know for just that that
spontaneity that you know just warmth
being able to just to relate to our
co-workers and others with with genuine
with genuine warmth where that's
possible I think part of the confusion
is the approach that we've tended to
have to matters around sexual harassment
you know I visited so many companies
where they'll say we have our policy and
they'll hold up you know this like you
know a thousand pages of dense you know
legalism legalese you know about this is
our sexual harassment policy and it sort
of outlines every sort of thing you
can't do and this and that and it's just
nonsense
it's nonsense because that's not the the
reality of workplace harassment or it's
not the total reality of workplace
harassment you know they're there one of
the things I talked about in the in the
book is a framework I developed I call
red light green light so think of a
traffic light you know there's the red
light is very clear stop you don't do
this and so when we think of harassment
yes you do not offer someone a job in
exchange for sex now that's pretty rare
actually these days it still happens and
the stories from Hollywood tells us it
still happens so yes we need you know we
need strong rules and regulations and
action if we see that so-called quid pro
quo harassment happening that's the red
light we say you cannot do this at work
green light is also pretty easy to deal
with it means you can be friendly to
coworkers
green lights don't tend to get people
into trouble think though in a city
where most accidents happen most
accidents happen at intersections and
they happen when the light is changing
when there's no clear red light or green
light there's this ambiguous orange
yellow amber
whatever you call that light in the
middle and I think that's where our
focus a lot of our focused on the
prevention of sexual harassment
education and training of managers
around sexual harassment has to happen
it's in that amber zone so for example
is it okay if I compliment you is it
okay to say hey you're looking good
today is it okay if I say that outfit is
fantastic is it okay if I flirt with a
co-worker is it okay if I ask someone on
a date is it okay if I touch someone and
the answer is it depends it depends on
the impact it depends on exactly what
you say on who you say it to on your
work relationship on your personal
relationship that touch it depends on
what you touch that compliment on your
body language your expression what
you're complimenting on and on we've got
to focus and these are like the the
amber light it's a warning sign so we've
got to focus our training of managers
and staff on these areas of confusion of
maybe maybe not to really develop a
language and a sensitivity that
harassment is about impact it's not
about your intention you might be your
intention might be to be wonderful and
welcoming it's not about your intention
it's about impact and so we've really
got to shift our language or discussion
around workplace harassment yes to
include the you know the most obvious
blatant things that include essentially
sexual assault but we have to go beyond
that to include all these more subtle
the amber light the yellow zone the
orange light whenever we call it area
[Music]